qu'est ce que tu fais là a mahdia pour
qui humana quand est ce que tu vas le
lui donner on l'a fait mal à la fête des
mères elle est célébrée chaque dernier
dimanche de mai depuis 1950
l'occasion idéale pour les petits des
grands d'offrir à leurs mamans
un cadeau et de redoubler d'imagination
en voici quelques-uns parfois insolites
grâce aux archives de la télé imposteur
poste heures en deux mots puisqu'il
s'agit d'une pendule à piles dont le
cadran est une photo agrandie de votre
maman
il y en a pour tous les goûts les
cadeaux un peu kitsch et les
incontournables bien sûr les dessins les
colliers de nouilles et autres fatah sel
mais dans les années 60 c'était
différent
à l'époque l'un des cadeaux envol pour
la fête des mères c'était ça le sablier
à 13 nouveaux francs lui permettra la
réussite de cet art difficile la cuisson
d'un oeuf à la coque
après le sablier pour cuisiner la croche
torchon encore une fois la mère de
famille n'échappait pas aux clichés tout
en cuir piqué avec des crochets le
cuivre et des petites ardoises c'est un
accroche torchon nouvelle vague les
décennies passent les mentalités
évoluent mais les cadeaux insolites eux
existent toujours
pour les mamans féminine et activent le
téléphone escarpins ou rouge baiser
le solitaire pas si seul utile au bureau
le capuchon de stylo couvert autre
cadeau étonnant le stage d'initiation au
maniement de la tronçonneuse
oui vous avez bien entendu ça se passe
en alsace et il est réservé uniquement
aux femmes elles apprennent donc à se
servir de l'engin de cette tronçonneuse
à maîtriser les différentes techniques
de coupe tout cas pour ma part je
continue à préférer le traditionnel
collier de nouilles voilà parmi tous ces
cadeaux vous n'avez plus qu'à faire
votre choix
et si jamais vous manquait encore
d'imagination n'oubliez pas vous pouvez
toujours pousser la chansonnette
tu vas le voir assis à laquelle le gone
donne
[Musique]